los padres de los más de 300 niños
secuestrados en nigeria temen que el
tiempo se acaba desde el viernes cuando
fueron raptados han ido a la escuela
secundaria ubicada en qantara en el
norte del país con la esperanza de
llegar a un acuerdo con boko haram el
grupo terrorista que se los llevó
ninguna mujer quiere estar en la calle a
esa hora pero no podemos dormir ni comer
pensando en nuestros hijos perdidos o
muy poquito pues cuando vemos al
personal de seguridad buscando en todos
los sitios nos da esperanza de encontrar
a nuestros niños
el grupo terrorista cuyo nombre
significa no a la educación occidental
se atribuyó este ataque en el estado de
catalina de donde procede el presidente
nigeriano muhammadu buhari el portavoz
del gobierno aseguró que había entablado
conversaciones con los secuestradores
pero algunos de los padres no creen que
haya sido poco hanan frank aguda
honestamente no creo en la autoría que
programa boko haram es una mentira
porque su líder está acostumbrada a
mentir para confundir a la gente si no
creo en sus palabras y la situación no
es la que dice ser
los fundamentalistas islámicos ya
adaptaron a 270 chicas hace 6 años en la
localidad de chivo al noreste en nigeria
este secuestro masivo consternó a la
opinión pública y generó un movimiento
de rechazo a nivel mundial con el
hashtag greenback our girls
sin embargo 112 de las niñas siguen
actualmente bajo el yugo de boko haram
en las redes sociales de nigeria ha
tomado fuerza la etiqueta brinda web
voice regresen a nuestros chicos en una
clara alusión a la campaña internacional
de 2014